is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster new measures to
trying to stamp out the coronavirus
variants
but how and when will the impact be felt
in our everyday lives
we'll be getting the latest from the
environment secretary george eustis
he's on the show in just a couple of
minutes also coming up
boots on the ground we meet the football
coach honored by the fa
for his mission to help youngsters from
deprived backgrounds
also coming up
thank you everyone has done it and all
your kindness
really kept me going love this uh
inspired by captain tom i'm going to be
speaking to the 11 year old
double amputee walking a second marathon
in honor of our hero it is tuesday the
9th of february
manchester mass testing and more
traveler checks the new measures
outlined
to fight the viral variants in the uk
poverty warning for hundreds of
thousands as mps push for the weekly 20
pound universal credit increase
to be extended for a year for me
and my family to have that removed our
anxieties
are going to be through the roof because
it will be a question between
fuel and food
searching for the truth we'll be live in
wuhan as the world health organization
prepares to reveal the results of its
investigation
into the original outbreak
clearing the streets we report from
haiti
as police and protesters clash in calls
for resignation of the president
minus 14 celsius in the highlands last
night and it'll be even
colder tonight and tomorrow night in the
north potentially
as low as -20 there'll be snow showers
two more details on those and the
warnings
before half past
morning all finding new ways to fight
the viral variants in the uk
mass testing is to be introduced in
parts of manchester
after cases of a new mutation of the
kent variant were confirmed
and there are new rules coming in at the
borders as well
let's take a closer look uh extra
covered tests for anyone arriving in the
uk
are expected to be announced later
passengers well they're going to have to
take two tests once in isolation
on day two and day eight after they
arrive
uh in manchester corolla various surge
testing is to be rolled out in parts of
the community
after four cases of a new mutation of
the kent variant of covert were found
still the deputy chief medical officer
jonathan van tam has moved to ease fears
over that south african coveted 19
variant he says
the mutation is unlikely to become the
dominant one
in the uk well the 20-pound weekly
increase to universal credit
it should be extended for one year to
prevent hundreds of thousands of people
including children
from falling into poverty that according
to a warning from a group of
mps at sky's molina veselinovich has the
detail
for anthony lyman providing for his
young daughter is tinged with worry
he's been declared bankrupt and relies
on the 20-pound weekly boost to
universal credit
to pay for food and bills but the uplift
introduced at the beginning of the
pandemic is set to end in april
leaving anthony worried about how he
will cope
for me and my family to have that
removed
our anxieties are going to be through
the roof because it will be a question
between
fuel and food or clothes and food you
know
it's it's something which will make a
massive massive impact yeah so it makes
us quite anxious
mps on the work and pensions committee
have called for the boost to be extended
for at least a year
writing in a report that removing it now
would plunge hundreds of thousands of
households including children into
poverty
for the millions already living in
poverty it would drag them down into
destitution
charities say the extra money helps the
poorest in society
a lot of these families they just about
and make ends meet and so 20 pounds a
week might not sound like much
but actually that enables them to keep
the lights on and put food on the table
quite literally
of our clients that are about to lose
out on this uplift 90
of them live in the poorest 10 of
households in the uk
that's the the profile of people that
we're talking about they're affected by
this
and so actually these households you
don't have a lot of other resources
a government spokesman said they were
committed to supporting the lowest paid
families through the pandemic
for people like anthony keeping that
commitment will make
all the difference milena veselinovich
sky news
ah well a year after the first deaths
from covert 19 were confirmed
in china sky news is hosting a series of
special programmes
to assess the uk's response to the
pandemic and any lessons learned
it all starts tonight my pal sophie
ridge is going to be your host
one year ago this week a new disease was
officially named
covert 19 has gone on to dominate all
our lives our work our friendships our
health
our homes even our futures everything
has changed
it's been a year of tragedy for many in
frustration for most but
also a time of remarkable advances in
science technology and healthcare
sky news has put together a
comprehensive timeline of every
significant moment
in an unprecedented year to help us
understand what we've got right
and what we may still be getting wrong
over the next three nights we'll be
assessing the uk response to the
pandemic
with some of the people behind that
response and others who've been affected
by it
join us the covert crisis learning the
lessons at 8 pm tonight wednesday and
thursday here on sky news
and so for the next three nights we'll
be asking whether we have learned any
lessons from coronavirus and discussing
how the country has responded
to the outbreak you can check out the
documents we've published on the sky
news mobile app
and go through the details yourselves of
the events
of the last year that's covert crisis
learning the lessons beginning tonight
8 p.m here on sky news
very pleased to say that the environment
secretary george eustis uh joins us
on the program mr eustis great to have
you on and uh thank you so much for for
braving the cold i know
exactly how cold it is just outside the
office this morning so
let's get rattling on as you've just
heard we're we're running a series of
special programmes
at this juncture in our response to
covet 19 to to assess where
where things have gone wrong and perhaps
some of the lessons learned
i wonder if you might identify one area
in which we
we have as a as a country changed our
response
one mistake that we made and have learnt
from
well look it's been an emerging
situation and
evidence has developed as time's gone on
and of course we've changed our approach
in some areas so
initially the advice was that uh there
wasn't a great deal of value in
wearing face masks as the evidence
emerged
the world health organization changed
that view and we changed
our advice in line with that so yes
this has been a dynamic evolving
situation the government's
you know responded to that and changed
its position in some areas for instance
face masks
um i i wonder then if we might dwell
just briefly
it is away from your brief but on on
universal credit then there is a
real pressure um from recipients of the
the 20-pound uplift
to politicians on your side of the the
chamber of the house of commons
is there any possibility that you know
in the immediate future we might get a
decision as to whether or not that that
20-pound uplift might last
substantially longer perhaps as long as
a year
well look obviously it's got a few more
months to run i think a couple more
months to run
and um rishi sunak i'm sure when he does
his budget we'll be looking at all these
issues carefully
we do know that it's affected household
incomes
and the resilience of households this uh
lockdown and the pandemic generally we
know and we've put in place
measures to help some of the most
vulnerable afford food because there's
been some issues with
families unable to afford food we've put
new measures in to support them and
we've
had this temporary uplift in the
universal credit at some point
we need to get back to normal get people
back
working again earning full salaries
again that's got to be
uh the route to recovery but i'm sure
that uh as we emerge from the lockdown
you know rishi sunak will be looking
carefully at the types of measures that
will be needed
uh to make that transition from lockdown
back to life as normal
um well let's talk about the variants
that are currently in the country at the
moment and clearly there has been a
degree of concern about about the south
african variant
particularly because of fears around the
efficacy of various uh
vaccines i i wonder if you might kind of
reiterate the points made by
jonathan van tam at yesterday's news
conference that look
you know we have to be mindful we have
to be concerned about these new variants
but the one which we are dealing with in
the united kingdom well the vaccines do
pretty well with that
yes and that remains uh our main
challenge at the moment is dealing with
a so-called kent variant
which is highly infectious spreads more
quickly than some of the other variants
and dominates at the moment and is our
primary challenge
and the vaccines are fully efficacious
against at that particular strain
but we constantly monitor other variants
around the world
there is always a risk that there will
be a variant that manages to to
circumvent
the vaccines that we have and that's why
we have to constantly redouble our
efforts to evolve the vaccine so that
they can deal with any new
variants that might arrive but also why
we are
you know constantly looking and
toughening our approach to quarantine
for those
arriving from overseas because until we
have an ability to
to vary the vaccine and update the
vaccine to meet those new challenges
we do have to exercise some caution
about international travel and that's
why
we put in place the measures we have
sure but but just in terms of the south
african variant
the case is numbered less than a couple
of hundred at the moment according to
to jonathan van tan but but given that
there is an eight-day process
for us to be able to sequence uh
sequence an individual case and discover
whether it's the south african
variant given the fact that we
understand that community transmission
is taken
has taken place it is by no means
beyond possibility that we could see a
surge in the south african variant isn't
it
well that we we can't be complacent but
i think what professor van tam
said yesterday is that the evidence so
far suggests that the south african
variant is actually less contagious than
the kent one so
it travels at a lower speed it hasn't
got that
that highly infectious rate that we see
in the kent
variant it's here in very small numbers
now so we have to
obviously monitor it very closely but
it's also the case that while there had
been concerns
uh that some of the vaccines the
asteroid vaccine might not be
fully effective against the south
african variant you know those concerns
have also receded somewhat in that you
know the
the evidence seems to say that it it
prevents some of the most
uh serious symptoms of the virus and
therefore
does provide some protection um once
again minister i appear to be learning
from the papers that we're going to be
seeing some toughening up around
uh around our borders and you you you
alluded to it a second ago
is it the case that we are now going to
see people who arrive here in the united
kingdom
mandatory testing day two day after
their arrival
well look i i don't think a final
decision has been made
on that but we do keep all of this under
review we've stopped short of having a
sort of total
closure of the border at this stage we
actually think that
uh it causes a lot of disruption but
doesn't uh add
a huge amount whereas the measures we
have put in place already
we require a pre-travel test
and the carriers are required to check
that test before passengers board
we require everybody to quarantine for a
period when they arrive here
and as you know we've introduced new
measures to ensure that those coming
from high-risk countries
will quarantine in hotels in future
there is a there is a case for doing
some
uh testing during quarantine we already
have a provision to
so that they can test to release from
quarantine earlier
and we're obviously looking at this to
see whether we can strengthen these
measures further
if a decision has not yet been made why
once again am i
learning about something in the
newspapers why once again
has briefing been made presumably by
someone relatively senior in the civil
service or relatively senior in
government
and the papers are once again
speculating about it
well look uh i as you uh as you know
neil i was once a
press secretary and we often end up
reading things in the papers that we
would prefer not to
um the reason i can only uh presume that
it has appeared in the papers is that it
is
a subject that's being discussed at the
moment within government
i don't think a final decision has been
made but i understand
you know matt hancock may be looking at
this further today
and obviously if a decision is made then
he'll make a
an announcement at that point but um you
know for now we've got
in place the measures we have we're
constantly looking at refining things
we don't rule out uh things like um post
quarantine or during quarantine testing
we already have it for people to release
from quarantine early
but you know i don't want to prejudge
anything matt hancock might say
sure but but on another and particularly
related topic quarantine hotels we did
have the announcement that those would
be introduced at some point we had an
announcement that there would be an
announcement we still do not yet know
when that announcement is going to be
what we do learn from the papers this
morning is that perhaps one of the
reasons why we haven't been able to move
forward with that
is that the government hasn't been able
to book a hotel room
well look i know that the department for
health
are working on this working with some of
the hotel operators they're in
discussion about
uh procuring those hotel rooms uh we've
got a policy in place that from the 15th
of february that's
next monday people coming from those
high-risk countries will have to
quarantine in hotels
i'm confident that we will have that uh
provision
in place and i'm aware that discussions
are ongoing at the moment
have we booked any hotels though because
the the strong implication and what
indeed the story in the papers this
morning is that we haven't booked them
we haven't picked any
well my understanding is and this is
obviously a procurement issue that
officials in the department of health
are dealing with
my understanding is that they are in
discussion with operators
uh those discussions have not yet
concluded but they're confident that
they will conclude
in good time for the quarantine policy
to start on the 15th of february as
planned
um can i just talk briefly about about
vaccine passports we heard from from the
deemesa harvey that vaccine passport's
not something that the government is
going to be doing i just wonder what the
government's position is
on companies private publicly traded
companies
insisting on people who access their
services
demonstrating that they have had a
vaccine let's say restaurants let's say
pubs
what would be the government's position
on that
well i think it'll hopefully be
unnecessary in the sense that
uh within the next week or so we hope to
have vaccinated
all uh of the uh most vulnerable cohorts
all of the over
70s were already well on the way there
with i think over 90 percent of the over
75s
now vaccinated and the reality is that
as we start to
you know emerge from lockdown when that
moment comes and the prime minister will
be
outlining that uh that journey on the
22nd of february
by the time we start to loosen that
lockdown then we
we will have vaccinated all of those
most vulnerable cohorts
and therefore you know the risk recedes
and it probably wouldn't be worth a
while of any individual business
trying to check whether people have been
vaccinated so our approach to
vaccination is to vaccinate the most
vulnerable cohorts in order and to to
roll out the vaccine as quickly as
possible
i very very much doubt that it'll be
worth anybody's while checking whether
someone's been vaccinated simply because
i say many of the most vulnerable will
have been by the time we get to easing
lockdown
sure what what then of of within the
health services
itself the royal college of nursing has
released data that says that you know 15
of nurses remain unvaccinated and that
is for for a variety of reasons
but of those who remain unvaccinated
sorry of those nurses that they pulled
four percent had decided not to take the
vaccine
can we conceive of circumstances in
which we would not insist on
frontline healthcare professionals
having the vaccine
if they had been offered it
well look i think it's always very
difficult to
require or mandate vaccination in that
way
it's always been the case that uh people
have to to choose to
to want it obviously it's disappointing
if there's people in
uh you know working in our nhs who
themselves in small very small numbers
have decided not to have the vaccine
we want to get maximum protection
particularly for those vulnerable
cohorts
but also for those such as those working
in the nhs who are particularly exposed
and the vast majority of them have taken
up the vaccine
mr eustis thanks once again for joining
us in the programme get inside and get
yourself warm just as soon as possible
thank you uh let's bring in kate mccann
who was listening
to our conversation with george eustison
look it does rather feel
we are on the cusp of getting quite a
bit of new information about what's
going to be happening at the borders
i think we will but i think what we also
got there was the confirmation that the
government now feels the time is right
to do that because george eustis was
saying
that the concern around new variants
does mean that there need to be
tougher measures now although he
wouldn't confirm what is in the papers
and what we're reporting today that
there will be testing on day two and day
eight of self-isolation that's for
people not in those quarantine hotels
that's a pretty certain policy measure
and there will be others that matt
hancock the health secretary
will likely announce if not today than
in the coming days but
there were a couple of moments there
that i thought were fascinating you
asked him about you know why haven't you
booked any hotels yet and he said
discussions are ongoing
this policy comes into force from monday
yeah at the moment we don't know
exactly how it's going to work we don't
know how much it's going to cost we
don't know which hotels are going to be
involved and there are some real
concerns about the ability of hotels
to be able to provide this service on
such short notice even though it's
important to say
people shouldn't be traveling right now
and the number of people coming into the
country
is relatively small one final note
though i think george justice gave us a
hint about how we could potentially get
out of tougher quarantine measures
because he said until the vaccine can be
tweaked reliably to cope with any new
variants
then they do need to be tougher measures
at the borders and that gives you a
sense of the time scale we're looking at
here
we know that there could be a new tweak
in the autumn particularly for the south
african variant but if that's when we
start to see some of those measures put
in place and that might be when the
government starts to lessen
some of those restrictions okay much
more from you throughout the day
thanks very much indeed uh but still to
come for you on the programme
a month after brexit how is the fishing
industry
coping with new trading rules i'm going
to be live with cornish fisherman chris
vinicom
at 20 past eight
the nhs says it's worried about falling
numbers of people from black asian and
ethnic minority groups going for vaccine
appointments scotland's first black
professor the life scientist so jeff
palmer is with us
at 8 30.
the football coach dan weston has been
honored for his work to redistribute
boots to the most disadvantaged children
he's the winner
of a national football award and we're
going to be talking to him
at water to tech
experts from the world health
organization will review details
about their investigation into the
origins of coronavirus the team have
just concluded a visit to wuhan province
in china
where the outbreak was first identified
our asia correspondent tom cheshire
is there the who have been here in wuhan
for four weeks now to that in a very
strict hotel quarantine while they're
still working
and then for the last two weeks they've
moved to this hotel they've been out and
about in wuhan itself seeing some of the
key sites including
seafood market where the first cluster
of covert 19 cases was discovered
also hospitals speaking to medics there
and the wuhan institute of virology
where some alleged
that the virus might have escaped
although researchers there strongly
deny that all through that time it's
been a very strictly controlled trip
it's been very hard for journalists to
get anywhere close really to the who
team
we have spoken to members of that team
on an individual basis who have given us
interviews but in terms of access
it has been very tightly controlled that
will change today they're going to give
their press conference
they're going to present a report as a
result of what they've been doing over
the last four weeks they're going to
give their evidence
and then they will be taking questions
from the press now they have warned this
is unlikely to reveal the exact origins
of covert 19 we're not going to know the
mechanism or the exact location
what they're hoping to do is know where
to look next really know the best
avenues for further research everyone it
could take years
before we know where covet 19 came from
i think the three
theories really that most people are
interested in at this point are the idea
that perhaps it did leak from the wuhan
institute of biology we'll hear about
that
what chinese officials have been saying
could have happened is imported into
china uh through
cold food imports uh they say this is a
phenomenon with kobe 19 they say as my
how the pandemic
might have started and then there's the
last theory really there's one that most
virologists believe that this started in
the animal population perhaps in bats
somewhere in southern china or southeast
asia
and made its way to humans so we'll hear
a bit more about those theories when
that press conference starts
some of the days on the news now and
donald trump's lawyers have again denied
he encouraged his supporters to stun
congress
during that violent protest in
washington dc last month
the former president is due to face a
second impeachment trial in the senate
although he is not going to be giving
evidence
a huge rescue operation is continuing in
india
after at least 26 people were killed
when a glacier collapsed and created a
huge torrent of
water and mud amongst the missing are 37
power plant workers thought
to be trapped in a tunnel
figures out today suggest that around
600 000 cases of coronavirus may have
been prevented
by the nhs coveted 19 test and trace app
the system uses bluetooth to keep an
anonymous record of when people come
into close contact with each other
the data also suggests around 2 million
people across england and wales
have now been advised to self-isolate by
the app
investigators have revealed that a
hacker in florida gained access to a
city's
water treatment plant the attacker
attempted to increase the amount of
sodium hydroxide in the water
but was stopped when a member of staff
intervened at sodium hydroxide is used
to treat water acidity but can
in large quantities cause burns
after decades of instability haiti is
descending once more into virtual civil
war
the president is refusing to stand down
excuse me at the end of his five-year
term
claiming he is still entitled to another
year in office
well it's prompted violent clashes
between the security services
and protesters in haiti's capital sky's
chief correspondent stuart ramsey
has this report
billowing clouds of tear gas fill the
streets across the capital
anti-government protesters chased down
and smoked out by the police
every age group is involved in this
street battle the stinging gas
can't be avoided
this was a day promising revolution
against president moisea
it was consistently and indiscriminately
stamped out
drive-by shootings by the police
continues
this is where protest marches usually
form up
they try setting fires and building
barricades
but the security forces were having none
of it
police units moved into the crowds
firing continuously
tear gas rounds handguns and rifles
it's working they're right around the
corner from us these guys keep training
danny
[Music]
the people say the president has failed
to do anything has overseen mass
corruption but worst of all
has allowed kidnapping for ransom to
grow into the country's biggest growth
business
communities are terrorized by kidnap
gangs
now they barricade themselves in
protecting themselves with machetes the
rich
and the poorest are all targets for the
kidnapping
and they blame the president in terms of
if what happens if he doesn't leave
a disorganized political opposition say
they will continue their moves to oust
the president
but each day this country already one of
the poorest in the world
is sliding into absolute anarchy
stuart ramsey sky news haiti
time now to see how the weather is
looking today i think you might have an
idea
isabel has the details and uh i think
we've got a lost temperature recorded
somewhere isabel
minus 15.1 alt nahara in highland my
goodness coldest of the winter
and it looks as though neil it'll be
even colder tonight and tomorrow night
it could well get as low as minus 20.
not a record but my word exceptional
and we've got warnings out the easterly
wind bringing further snow showers
an amber warning in force for central
and eastern scotland
let's take a look at the detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
the amber warning in force across
central and eastern scotland until
9 00 pm this evening 10 to 15
centimeters potentially 20 centimeters
more snow expected there
and blowing around with that east wind
too there'll be bands of snow showers
coming in in other areas as far as
dublin actually seeing some snow this
morning but there's some very heavy snow
coming through the wash down into the
north midlands at the moment
and there'll be more snow showers across
eastern areas as you can see some of
them getting further west but
brighter skies for the west generally
most cloudy most snowy in eastern areas
where it'll still feel very cold and
after that widespread sharp frost this
morning
temperatures barely above freezing still
that wind chill and particularly
cold in the wind across the south where
it'll be really gusty
and lively those winds through the
course of the day now as we head through
this evening tonight the winds do ease a
touch particularly across the north
where as i said
very low temperatures there a widespread
frost hills elsewhere
with snow probably continuing down the
eastern side of the country tonight
and during the day tomorrow still
further snow showers mainly i think for
northeast england around the coast of
east anglia
further west and north clearer and
sunnier and with lighter winds it does
mean
an exceptionally cold night wednesday
night
well the health secretary matt hancock
is expected to announce that travellers
arriving in the uk will have to undergo
extra covert tests passengers are said
to have to take
two tests whilst in isolation on day two
and day eight after they arrive speaking
to us earlier the environment secretary
george eustis said
the challenge was to find the most
effective way of stopping new cases of
covert 19 coming into the country
i don't think a final decision has been
made on that but we do keep all of this
under review
we've stopped short of having a sort of
total closure
of the border at this stage we actually
think that
it causes a lot of disruption but
doesn't uh add a huge amount
there is a there is a case for doing
some uh testing during quarantine we
already have a provision to
so that they can test to release from
quarantine earlier
and we're obviously looking at this to
see whether we can strengthen these
measures further
now let's take you back to universal
credit and the calls to extend the
weekly 20 pound extra for a year
um let's speak now to rebecca now she's
a single mom uh with one daughter
she herself is is currently on universal
credit rebecca
great to have you on this morning and
thanks for thanks for speaking to us
about this
um just give us a little idea of the
situation that you're in at the moment
and
and how important how significant that
extra 20 quid has been to you
well so like you say i'm a single parent
um
on universal credit i'm also working
um so you know i'm doing my best but
still
i'm barely paying for the essentials
belly
managing to pay for food heating um
bills and everything so that 80 pounds
a month is is a huge contribution
that basically makes sure that we have
food on our table
and if you consider removing that when
resource is already tight
during a pandemic during everything
that's happening and winter
um it's obviously making me very very
nervous and scared to the idea of losing
that 80 pounds
i'm am i right in saying that you're
also studying part-time as well rebecca
so you've got you've got
i've just gone back to university at the
open university to try and you know
better my situation
um so doing everything yeah
yeah so so just you've got child care
presumably that you've got to be worried
about you've got studies that you've
started with
you're trying to work um i mean if the
the university
there is still some time to run on the
additional 20 pounds
but if it comes to an end in the not too
distant future
where do you think you almost feel the
pinch what will have to go
when that 80 pounds does go
um i guess it's all sort of luxuries so
um for example my daughter loves singing
so i spend ten pounder like a fortnight
on singing lessons
for her um it's trying to
instead of we'll have to try and find
some way to get her clothes when she
runs out of clothes
i don't know how but we will and you
know often
something that happens is that i i fall
behind in
rent because that's something that you
can cut back on for a month and then
make the
make the money back up again by paying a
little bit extra
so um it's it's very uh
you know it's everything is so tight i
budget to the penny
so that when something like this happens
it's there's not much wriggle room
there's not much space for you know
anything yeah and and of course you know
our energy bills
i don't know what the temperature is
like with you this morning but it is
fairly freezing just outside our front
door and you know your energy costs are
going to be significantly higher
at least for the next few days
yeah absolutely plus we're on lockdown
so i don't have the luxury of just
turning the heater off
and i'm just cold all the time which is
what i used to do because i
i can't do that to my daughter so i keep
the heating on all the time
and you know the lights on and yeah it's
like the alps outside you know it's
it's real you know it's real cold so um
that's obviously a real big concern and
um it's it's difficult now but i
worry most about next winter
because i won't have any i won't have
any savings or anything
so um i don't if we lost that 80 pounds
i genuinely am
worried about how we'd get through next
winter
let alone this winter and how's how's
your wee one doing how's your daughter
coping because of course
there's going to be i presume a degree
of being taught from home by
mum isn't that
yeah you know i'm i'm lucky that she's
a resilient joyful little creature you
know she's the greatest little kid in
the world
but um she's struggling and she also
now that she's a she understands a sort
of concept of poverty
so she knows that we don't have very
much
and she knows that things cost money
and you know so i think she i think i
tried to take the worries away from her
as much as possible
and give her everything but she's
starting to see
for herself that things can be a
struggle and that there's a
discrepancy in society between those who
have and those who have not
which is horrible that shouldn't be the
case you know
um well rebecca thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us this
morning
and hope you and the wee one do stay
nice and warm
thank you and i hope you have a lovely
day
uh also this morning labour is calling
for an extension to the support given to
businesses during the pandemic they say
many firms are facing a funding
bombshell in the coming months uh lucy
powell the shadow business minister
uh the secretary of state joins us on
the programme ms paul great to have you
on and i'll talk about that in just a
second
but i wonder if we might just get
comment from you on that which you have
heard
there is certainly a degree of pressure
uh building upon the chancellor on the
government to to continue with that 20
pounds
uplift does labor have an end date for
when that 20
pounds uplift should come to an end
well i mean the government we're going
to need to look at this in the long term
aren't they but we certainly think that
for
for the next year for for while people
are dealing with the with the pandemic
that that is absolutely
uh critical but i thought your interview
there with rebecca
really spoke volumes uh about what that
means to her
how it is really the difference between
being able to sort of feed her
uh child or or not and you know what uh
what a a lovely interview and lovely
family they are
and and and how desperate they are
really and
and that's why it's so important that we
that we look to extend it but it it's
also about
it doesn't actually make economic sense
to cut that at the moment either
i think that's the other point that we
we would want to make because
that's taking money out of the economy
it's taking money away from
people being able to spend in their
local shops and
their local high streets and that's
that's going to be the wrong timing as
well
if that happens in april just as as
shops and that sort of
start to reopen yeah i think it behooves
all of us who are not lucky enough to be
in rebecca's position to remind
ourselves there are people out there for
whom
20 pounds is it makes a huge difference
but let's go on to what labour is
discussing today this
50 billion pound bombshell awaiting
businesses
come april uh what's that
so unfortunately we've got this massive
sort of bombshell of all of these
cliff edges coming around all at the
same danger point at the beginning
of april uh businesses have deferred
their vat
payments for last year that's about 34
billion pounds that they're going to
have to start repaying
from the beginning of april the business
rate holiday
is due to come to an end so businesses
are gonna have to start paying
uh business rates at the beginning of
april that's nearly
uh 10 billion and then of course the
furlough scheme is coming to an
end as well as other loans that
businesses will have taken out
will have to start being repaid at that
point and
and unless this is addressed urgently by
the government it can't wait till the
budget now
unless it's addressed this bombshell is
going to
blow a big hole in our economy and it's
gonna i'm
i'm really worried it's going to lead to
um
tens of thousands of businesses going
bust and in fact the
federation of small businesses have
warned that
uh 250 000 businesses could are at risk
of going bust in the next few months so
that's why we want to see the government
extend
the business rate holiday for at least
six months we want them to extend
the furlough scheme while public health
restrictions are in place and we want
them to continue
uh the cut in vat for the hospitality
which is one of the hard-pressed
sexes because of course many of these
businesses don't even know if they can
reopen in april yet
let alone start to pay these bills sure
and i'm not i'm not doting your
sincerity in all of this but isn't this
just a really easy political hit
for the labour party you and i both know
that at some point these schemes
will not just have to come to an end but
but they will have to be paid for it
will be a difficult political
decision whenever that takes place and
frankly a year two years from now
one imagines that businesses will still
be feeling the effects of
of covert 19. i mean it is isn't the
case that you know
this these schemes will have to end at
some point
and perhaps it's better to bite the
bullet now take the financial hit
and rebuild rather than storing it up
for you know six months 12 months two
years down the line
well it's not an easy decision to call
for these things to be extended
at all and look there's there's two two
reasons for why we
we think these things need to be
extended you know firstly
we we can't afford not to do it because
the cost to the economy the cost to the
exchequer and the public purse
of tens of thousands of businesses going
bust and all those jobs being lost
will cost our economy a great deal more
in the long run
um because the the recovery will be
choked off because there won't be
businesses there
to power it there'll be higher levels of
unemployment which are already very high
and that costs
us as taxpayers a great deal of money in
terms of
benefit payments and so on and there's
lost tax revenue so
we can't afford not to do it from that
point of view and the second thing is
that these economic support measures
have to keep pace with public health
measures
we we've we've already um supported and
invested
in businesses a great deal over the last
year rightly so
as we've asked them to close to keep us
all
safe from this pandemic now would be
just the wrong point to pull the rug
on that support as we can see the
reopening of the economy
and the recovery on the horizon with the
vaccination program so
all that good money if you like will go
would go to waste
if we don't maintain that support
through this critical period and
businesses are really worried today
about how they're going to
meet these huge bills that councils the
councils are sending out the
business rate bills as we speak and
businesses are really worried
about how they're going to pay for that
in april especially if they're not even
going to be open by then
ms pearl i'm very conscious that we have
to let you go but just just briefly
a word from you on on that which we're
expecting once again to hear from the
government it's trailed in the papers
but the ministers can't tell us anything
about it
uh the people arriving here in the
united kingdom will have to have
two coveted tests day two day day eight
of their isolation
sure that's something you'd welcome well
we would welcome it but i mean i think
the issue here is that our
our our borders have not been secured
from from elsewhere uh particularly the
south african
uh variant so we we really worried about
that and so
the government said they were gonna
impose the hotel quarantine
that's not happened uh and now we've got
these other measures coming in so they
should have taken action
earlier and stronger to secure our
borders and stop people
coming in to this country without
quarantining
lucifer good to see you this morning
thanks for being with us thank you
now police have used water cannon to
break up protests in
several major cities in myanmar uh some
use in just the last few minutes uh the
authorities have extended areas
where gatherings are restricted uh let's
get the views of our
southeast asia correspondent siobhan
robbins uh joining us this morning good
to see you siobhan
um well that water cannon for starters a
one-off yesterday
it is now a tactic are we actually to
view what we're seeing today as an
escalation of a crackdown
100 we are definitely seeing an
escalation in force being used by the
authorities today
we've seen water cannon being used
against peaceful protesters in a number
of areas including mandalay which is the
second
biggest city napierdore which is the
capital lining up
in yangon at the moment no reports it's
been fired so far bago
which is outside yangon also in napier
door police fired rubber bullets into
the air in order
to disperse crowds there that hasn't
worked but there are reports that
several people have been
injured and also as you say there have
been
extensions of curfews night curfews in
some areas also rules saying that people
can't gather in sizes of more than five
none of it's working the protesters are
continuing to gather
and the force of the authorities is also
growing stronger
siobhan many thanks
coming up after the break i'm going to
be speaking with one adult with
disabilities
as she prepares to receive her
coronavirus vaccine
that's next welcome back uh there are
nine priority groups who are among the
first to be offered the vaccine high up
on that list is of course
at the category so-called at-risk adults
which
includes those uh with learning
disabilities um
very pleased to say uh we're joined now
by lucy
who herself is in assisted living and
she is set to have the vaccine
later today and very good morning lucy
how are you this morning
ah say um good good
but i'm very pleased to hear it this is
a big day isn't it
you're going to be getting the vaccine
later on
yeah and how is that making you feel
um i further more happy
really is there any business
is there any bits of you lucy that's
maybe a little bit nervous about it all
um well
i it won't
it won't that's good you're
you're a braver you're a braver lady
than i am 100
but there must so tell me a bit about
how coronavirus has been because it has
meant that you haven't been able to see
friends and family as much as possible
um this is a bit irritable
i didn't see in my family at um a long
time
and i miss my friends and
it's a bit irrical and um
um this is a bit trick
tricky one i
i so then lucy are you are you looking
are you looking forward then
to the point when you can give i know
your nieces and nephews would be very
much looking forward to seeing you
when you can give everyone a big hug
yeah i am yeah
and so yeah
oh no dude don't you worry i'm more
nervous than you this morning believe
you me
i'm more nervous than you but with all
the cold weather
and with everyone getting the sniffles
and with coronavirus this is a good day
for you because at some point you know
it means that things
might be coming to a little bit of an
end and that things all might get a
little bit easier for all of us
um yeah um
i'm very um
um i feel a bit more confident
in myself really and um
maybe more after myself
and more well that no do you know what
that is really good to hear because
you're competing with me
for confidence this morning you're on
tele all around the world at the moment
so you should be very pleased with
yourself so god tell me what
what's the one thing lucy that you're
looking forward to doing
more than anything else that you haven't
been able to recently
um well well
it because um
because i'm a bit um
it's not easy um
um
don't you worry don't you worry lucy
look
it's a big day ahead of you but it's all
safe and sounds
you're going to get the vaccine and you
know fingers crossed
everything's going to be a lot better in
the not too distant future you heard it
here first okay
lucy thank you for taking the time to
talk to us this morning i hope it's a
good day